في جنيف ، رد رئيس منظمة الصحة
العالمية على
انتقادات الجسد إذا كنت لا تريد المزيد من
حشرات الجسم ، ثم تمتنع
عن تسييسها.
قال ترامب إنه من الخطر أن تصبح سياسيًا
أثناء الوباء ، فلا داعي لاستخدام النسخ
لتسجيل نقاط سياسية ،
فلا داعي لأن يكون لديك العديد من الطرق الأخرى لإثبات أن
هذا ليس الأسلوب الذي يجب
استخدامه للسياسة ، إنه مثل اللعب
بالنار في اليوم السابق للسيد.  انتقد ترامب
من زعم أنك لم ترفع إن
ارات كافية بشأن الفيروس الذي وص
وه بأنه خطأ ، ووصفوه بأنه خطأ ، فق
فاتهم حقًا المكالمة التي كان من الممكن أن
سموها قبل أشهر وكانوا عل
علم بها ور
ما كانوا يعرفون  لذلك سننظر
في ذلك بعناية فائقة في
تصريحاته يوم الأربعاء أشار المدير العام
لـ W Cho إلى أن
المنظمة كانت تتابع عن
كثب وتصدر تحذيرات بشأن الفيروس
منذ أوائل يناير السيد.  انتقد ترامب أيضًا
برنامج W8 لعدم
دعمه حظر سفر الأشخاص القادمين من
الصين وقالوا إنه لا
توجد مشكلة كبيرة ، لا توجد مشكلة كبيرة ولا يوجد
شيء ، وبعد ذلك في النهاية
عندما أغلقته قالوا في الواقع أنني
ارتكبت خطأ في إغلاقه.  وتبين أنه كان
صحيحًا ، فقد وجد تقرير لقناة CNN
أنه على الرغم من أن ترامب محق
في من لم يدعم
قيود السفر مع الصين ، إلا أنه
يعارض معظم
قيود السفر الدولية ويرى أنها
غير فعالة وفي حين لا يخاطب السيد.
انتقادات ترامب المباشرة
دعا المدير العام الولايات المتحدة والصين إلى
التعاون الآن ، ويجب على الولايات المتحدة
والصين أن تتعاون معًا لمحاربة
هذا العدو الخطير الذي يجب أن
يتحدوا لمحاربته السيد.  قال ترامب أيضًا
مرارًا وتكرارًا إنه من كان
متمحورًا حول الصين ، قال المدير العام
إنهم لا يلعبون المرشحون إذا بدوت
سيئًا
على مر السنين ، حتى أن هناك الكثير جدًا من
كل شيء يبدو متحيزًا جدًا
تجاه الصين ، وهذا ليس صحيحًا ، فنحن
قريبون من كل دولة.  نحن مصابين بعمى الألوان
نحن ما نسميه Wells Blind
لا نرى بالنسبة لنا الأغنياء والفقراء هو
نفسه بالنسبة لنا الضعفاء والقوة هو نفسه
بالنسبة للصغير والكبير هو نفسه بالنسبة لنا نحن
الأشخاص الموجودين في  الجنوب أو في
الشمال الشرقي أو الغربي هي نفسها نقطة واحدة لدينا
يوم الثلاثاء السيد.  قال ترامب إنه
سيعلق تمويل المنظمة
رغم أنه نفى في وقت لاحق قول ذلك
ثم أوضح أنه
سيبحث في الأمر فقط إنه أحد عملاء سواريز سي إن إن.